the ukraine story according to the
american media demonizing vladimir putin
won't get it done
state-controlled reporting in russia
takes a hit
more and more journalists there are
quitting their jobs
plus politics and tourism intersect
online the influencers on tour in syria
hello i'm richard gizbert and you're at
the listening post where we dig into the
coverage and examine how news is being
reported for the past month this program
like much of the world's media has been
focused squarely on ukraine last week we
looked at the black hole where russia's
news and information space used to be
and the criminalization of dissent there
this week we're turning to the media
debate on ukraine in the u.s which is
showing some disturbing signs of
groupthink at times american news
outlets can be like mirrors they tend to
reflect washington's foreign policy
consensus
former cold war warriors ex-military and
intelligence officials populate the
airwaves there is a significant shortage
though on the historical context on nato
its gradual expansion across eastern
europe that can be dangerous such topics
might sound slightly off the mark when
russian bombs are hitting maternity
hospitals in ukraine but history is
loaded with examples of the perils that
come with uncritical reporting and a
rush of militarism our starting point
this week is ukraine the american angle
a major question
starting with a proviso that we hear
again and again
one that american journalists or
analysts seem compelled to make when
discussing ukraine well before i say
anything else i just want to say that
this invasion of ukraine is a criminal
action by vladimir putin
and
that is the context in which everything
is happening and i don't want to say
anything that could be mistaken for not
understanding that
now that said of course failing to say
that or something along those lines on
the american airwaves let alone on
social media puts one at risk of being
branded a putin sympathizer
it should be possible to discuss
the larger geopolitical context
including many mistakes made by western
policymakers while at the same time
laying the blame for for the immediate
conflict on vladimir putin where it
belongs
it should also be possible for the
coverage to include the basic context
the nato question and moscow's point of
view on the planned expansion of the
western military alliance right to
russia's southwestern border it should
be but seldom is
what you're going to see instead is them
basically legitimizing the presence of
nato and using russia's invasion to
further legitimize that nato needs to be
on russia's doorstep and it needs to be
in ukraine in the future what they
should really be talking about is how
did we get to this place
representatives of 12 nations of western
europe and north america assemble for
the signing of the north atlantic treaty
nato was constructed to basically
provide a counterweight to the soviet
union why does nato still exist 30 years
after the collapse of the soviet union
we should be asking that question
president trump once again raised doubts
about his commitment to nato
you'll remember that when trump was
president he would make the case that
nato was outdated that nato was
irrelevant what vladimir putin has done
extremely well is make the case for nato
right like vladimir putin has really
been an advertisement for nato in my
mind we're in a very interesting time
with the nato discourse
then there's the binary issue
and the baggage many american
journalists still carry from the
so-called war on terror
this is about good versus evil this is
about people who want to destroy us our
civilization and our way of life
20 years ago on iraq u.s mainstream news
outlets sold their audiences on a
narrative the wmds only to discover
there were none and that the geopolitics
were far more complicated than they made
them out to be
still suffering from their own case of
post-iraq ptsd
american reporters and commentators seem
more comfortable with the ukraine story
i can't imagine attacking a country in
which virtually everyone hates us
as opposed to applauding us and we
should remember in iraq they did applaud
us it's apparent simplicity allows for
the return of the good old good versus
evil narrative
when it's good versus evil you gotta
sometimes when you're on the good side
have some ambiguity about discerning
the real evil from the somewhat evil i
guess a lot of that for me stems from
this anxiety of the war in iraq frankly
the u.s media for the last 20 years
they've been dealing with a war that
doesn't adequately respond to these
types of good versus evil binaries
they've been dealing with the mass
destabilization of the middle east which
followed from the invasion of iraq in
2003
i think for many in the mainstream media
particularly the cable news media the
invasion of ukraine is an opportunity to
reframe that if we can get enough in
there they'll push the russians out it
will be a tremendous win for the west
and it'll be a real failure for putin
they're still mostly old guard cold war
figures who want to see the old cold war
re-establish itself because that's the
world that they understand we have this
bad actor vladimir putin who's on the
side of evil whereas the us and nato are
on the side of good
american cable news is terrible at
injecting any amount of context into
anything
good evening taking advantage of that
gap in context is tucker carlson of fox
news
better known for providing hyperbole
than nuance and still prone to
conspiracy theories on bio labs in
ukraine carlson does offer a rare
critical take on the white house's
position on this conflict the reason why
his show is so highly rated is because
the man is extremely good at what he
does
why in the world would the united states
intentionally seek war with russia
what he's done is not pro-putin because
that's impossible right you can't defend
bombing hospitals right killing babies
and right killing pregnant mothers you
can't defend that but you can be
or at least tucker has been able to be
anti-anti-putin no one who knows
anything and is honest will tell you
putin invaded ukraine simply because he
is evil so the idea is you're not
pro-putin you're just
against being against putin and i think
it's a fascinating way to twist a
narrative
the sanctions imposed on russia by the
west are having a punishing effect on
its economy and people at home and
abroad
new york's metropolitan opera house says
that any russian artist who supports
putin or is supported by him is no
longer welcome to perform there
fifa and uefa have banned russian clubs
and the national team from their
football tournaments the russian team is
also being scrubbed from fifa's video
game
just tune into american news programs
late night entertainment shows and you
will find an antipathy for all things
russian i hear you can get a job in
russia right away mining arsenic and
potash and whatever potash they don't
use for fertilizer you can get to eat
there's more mass xenophobia people
vandalizing russian businesses or
demeaning russians and to whatever
extent that's encouraged by mainstream
media outlets it's reprehensible and
misguided not only because it's bigoted
and thoughtless but because russian
people are not to blame for this war
this is putin's war and russian people
are in many cases protesting against
this war which in russia is a very
dangerous thing to do so anyone who's
angry rightly so about russia's invasion
of ukraine
is being very very misguided if they're
taking that out on regular russian
people
abby martin knows both sides of the
story she's an american journalist whose
past work has become a casualty of this
information war
from 2012 to 2015
martin worked for the kremlin funded
network rt
fronting a program called breaking the
set
earlier this month youtube did a mass
take down of material from russian news
sources and martin saw years of her work
journalism on a range of topics just
disappear
i have a lot of disagreements with rt
and the direction they took after i left
the network but i'm a free speech
absolutist and i feel like having the
russian perspective is a crucial thing
in this country when we are constantly
fearmongering and warmongering against
russia so breaking the set was banned my
entire catalog of critical interviews
about u.s imperialism about israel about
saudi arabia all of those were just
obliterated in the blink of an eye
this is the equivalent to modern book
burning and many are actually
celebrating it
without realizing what a slippery slope
that is the answer when you're
responding to a country that is
uh
arresting journalists and dissidents is
never to take down speech that is
critical of the official line and what
we're seeing on youtube maybe even more
than on facebook and twitter
is a real willingness to take down
anything that is critical of nato's role
in this conflict you're responding to a
propaganda war by creating your own
version of propaganda the way to
respond to speech that
contains misinformation or
disinformation is is not is never to
just remove it
ostracizing russians treating them with
suspicion should not be mistaken for a
just response
there are ways to be critical of what
vladimir putin is doing to the ukrainian
people without leaning into militarism
american journalism needs to make those
distinctions and put them to
use
nuance is always called for uh even even
in the case of an aggressive war and it
should be possible to recognize this war
for what it is
it should be possible to stand in basic
solidarity with ukraine without buying
into jingoistic or propagandistic
narratives there is room for
acknowledging complexity and history and
also basic judgments of right and wrong
and i think the media should be capable
of both at the same time from the u.s to
russia now where despite the kremlin's
determination to control the narrative
on ukraine some cracks have started to
appear johanna house is here with more
as we've been reporting criticism of
vladimir putin's invasion is hard to
come by in the russian media especially
on the country's tightly controlled
airwaves
state-backed channels parrot putin's
talking points and still refuse to call
the quote special operation a war
but this past week we've seen a stream
of resignations at some of the country's
top broadcasters
lilia gildeva a longtime anchor on ntv
and her colleague vadim glewsker who had
been at the channel for almost 30 years
both quit maria baronova rt's former
chief editor in moscow has cut ties with
the network over its quote willingness
to spread propaganda and then there's
what's been happening at rocia1 janna
agalakova the channel's europe
correspondent resigned reportedly over
its ukraine coverage and that was on the
back of the very public protest that
made news by an editor at that same
broadcaster marina of janikova
she crashed a live news class with a
placard condemning the lies her channel
was spreading about ukraine
ojanikova ended up getting fined about
300 us dollars but her case remains
under investigation i made this decision
by myself because i
don't like
[Music]
russia starts this
invasion the journalists making a stand
have been praised including by ukraine's
president vladimir zelinsky since
condemning the invasion calling it a war
is now a criminal offence in russia and
one that can lead to 15 years in jail
but these protests have been late in
coming and with the last of russia's
independent broadcasters tv dodged an
echo moscow radio shut down by the
authorities critical voices are in a
minority that by the kremlin's design
keeps shrinking
thanks joe
on to another conflict now where russia
has also played a central role syria
it was 11 years ago this week during the
arab spring that citizens there first
took to the streets peaceful protests
against the rule of president bashar
al-assad they were met with violence and
brutality today against long odds and
with a little help from some powerful
friends assad remains in power and other
governments are slowly quietly
re-establishing relations
in fact anyone browsing travel content
on social media would be forgiven for
thinking that normalization was already
a done deal
foreign travel bloggers have been
visiting damascus for years recently
they've even ventured into territory
that had been under opposition control
and was bombed accordingly by syrian and
russian forces the listening posts ahmed
mahdi now on the curious world of travel
vlogging and what looks like a victory
lap for the assad regime
friday was the bloodiest day
for crimes against humanity
for more than 10 years now the headlines
coming out of syria have depicted
dictatorship this is the war assad is
waging on his own people
nearly 12 000 children have been killed
or injured and destruction entire
neighborhoods lie destroyed
leaving an apocalyptic scene but in one
corner of the internet you can see a
very different side to syria i love
syria and you will not believe how
amazing it is
good evening guys right now i'm in
damascus thanks to some unlikely
visitors i first heard about travel
bloggers
to syria post-war
uh in 2019. good morning guys and
welcome to damascus syria i don't know
what to expect from damascus really but
this this wasn't really it
like
it feels like any other
nice touristy city it was amazing to see
damascus again that's where my mom lived
for quite some time and as a syrian i
got very emotional
seeing that footage and saying
it looks absolutely amazing seeing her
eating the ice cream and they give it to
her for free but mostly i remember being
kind of shocked that they were doing
that already this is the syrian stem the
travel vloggers were already heading to
syria as a travel destination we are in
japan guys another beautiful sunny day
here in barbados travel vlogging is a
huge online industry and to stand out
many vloggers have been visiting
so-called alternative travel
destinations
the kind more often seen in the
headlines than the travel brochures
it's a winning formula and it's
generated millions of views and dollars
for both the content creators and the
social media companies i was just so
hyped on all the positive things about
syria the people the food the love but
in a place like syria is this content
cutting corners with the truth
just to please the algorithms you know
when there's a war
it's not raining bombs on every single
inch of syria
people are still living there my family
is still there
they still you know go to work every day
but this very simplistic view of life in
syria lacks nuance of how life actually
is inside a war these streets that i saw
in the videos
are are real but they're very touristy
sierra is very big and it's not one one
neighborhood or
or one very instagrammable street
we just stopped for a photo of that look
at that i think that they pretty
accurately
reflect
the life of wealthy syrians in damascus
and that's kind of the the power of
inviting travel bloggers into that city
specifically
because it was less hard hit because
there are a lot of pro-regimes there's
been especially wealthy ones which are
very much in the minority many of them
are located in damascus so in terms of
inviting tourism into syria damascus is
a very safe bet
we asked the syrian tourism ministry
whether foreign travel influencers were
being invited into the country for pr
purposes
they didn't respond
what we do know is that every tourist
visiting syria travel vloggers included
is legally required to be accompanied at
all times by a government guide what
journalists would call a handler so
while vloggers are exploring the markets
of damascus
roaming the ruins of aleppo
[Music]
or chatting to locals
the eyes and ears of the government are
never far away
knows this firsthand
he's a travel vlogger who just returned
from syria a few weeks ago
of course i had to get a guide you
cannot just wander around yourself as a
tourist with a touristic visa in surya
i'm here with my guide mary
so what the guides do after you leave
the country they are reporting it to the
government where have you been and what
you have done in the country this is the
real nightlife of surya as of now check
this out
i was there during the christmas time
people were having fun in the cafes
having shisha so this is one of the
videos i shared as well but i also
shared other part of it the leftovers
from the civil war do you want to see
what civil war brings to the country
right now i'm in syria in the biggest
city called homs and all around me is
just destroyed buildings i think people
specifically suryans had very mixed
feelings about my content they were
thinking that i am sold out and i am
it's a propaganda for the government and
i'm actually paid to be in syria and
make this content which is absolutely
not true surya is not only about civil
war and depressing headlines hey dufu
fun fact on christmas day the same day
you posted that regime sponsored
propaganda six opposition fighters were
murdered in northern syria one of the
reasons why i made that tick talk about
davood is he specifically made a video
of some
destroyed buildings and his messaging
was
see what war gets you it gets you
nothing as a result this is what we have
left which to me was
very heart-wrenching there are results
of the war with the regime every travel
vlogger i'm aware of says well i'm not
political and but how can you show the
destruction of a political war and still
be apolitical when you go into a war
zone and say it's a political it's only
documentation
and you're showing only one side then if
you're documenting you should actually
do more research and more work and go to
places where
you know you don't have a fixer from
the side of the regime showing you
around this is a very political space
you're standing in
that is
under regime control and the regime is
showing you what they want the world to
know
[Music]
part of the problem is that journalists
are not being allowed in
except for media from countries the
regime considers friendly like russia
and iran states that have backed
president bashar al-assad few foreign
reporters have been able to visit
government held syria in recent years
that's left the vloggers and other more
controversial figures to fill the
information gap
blurring the lines between content
creator and journalists there was an
army created inside surya which they
called themselves free army and they
were fighting against syrian government
i'm not a journalist i'm just a simple
content creator and i feel like people
right now trust individuals and the
content creators more than the news what
i wanted to do is just show a little bit
different side and more authentic side
of surya surya will become and as a very
important destination for the region and
for the touristic destination as well
and i do feel like the content i share
helps it a little bit
despite the ongoing fighting
the millions of syrians displaced and
the fact that around a third of the
country remains beyond his control
assad is ready to reintroduce himself to
the world
states that had once denounced his rule
are now resuming diplomatic ties and
along with it lucrative energy and trade
deals
for the global news audience however
it's a much harder sell and that's why
the regime needs all the help it can get
when you have 10 years of conflict
afterwards comes you know the writing
history part the normalization with the
world part these vloggers are a very
small part of this plan
i personally don't think that
tourism right now in syria is ethical
it is only aiding
the
bigger message that the regime wants
to come across which is that syria is
safe syria is not safe especially not
for syrians who want to return every
syrian wants
the world
to hear and to see syria as they know it
as this beautiful
historical
magical place
and in that sense
who can blame the travel vloggers for
wanting to tell that story
but this tourism without journalism
is mostly harmful
i want the story of syria to be told
but i want the whole story told
and finally if you find tucker carlson
of fox news tough to take in english get
a load of what he sounds like in russian
the kremlin has cleansed western news
narratives on ukraine from the airwaves
it controls but it's clearly good with
carlson and his what has putin ever done
to us act on fox according to the
american news magazine mother jones the
russian government has instructed news
channels to broadcast as many carlson
clips as possible a number of outlets
are running with that dictate just take
a listen to one of the voices
translating carlson's words and decide
is that a slightly excitable voice of
translator or is it an act of mockery
we'll see you next time here at the
listening post
yes
[Music]
foreign
you